foreign
to the data science hangout if you're
joining for the first time it is so nice
to meet you I'm Rachel
the data science hangout is an open
space for the whole data science
Community to connect and chat about data
Science Leadership questions you're
facing and what's going on in the world
of data science
so these sessions are recorded and
shared to the rstudia YouTube as well as
the rstudio data science hangout site
try to get them up at least a week after
each session so you can always go back
and re-watch or find helpful resources
we also have a LinkedIn group for the
hangout too so if you ever want to
continue a certain discussion or if
anybody wants to talk to each other in
there other than me just talking in
there
um please feel free to join that group
and Tyler or Hannah will share it in a
second in the chat
together we're all dedicated to creating
a welcoming environment for everybody
here so we love when everyone can
participate and we can hear from
everybody so there's three ways that you
can ask questions today you can jump in
by raising your hand on Zoom you can put
questions in the zoom chat and feel free
to put a little star next to it if you
want me to read it or I can call on you
to introduce yourself and add some con
context to
lastly we also have a slido link where
you can ask questions anonymously and
Hannah will share that in the chat as
well
I just want to reiterate before we get
started that we love to hear from
everybody no matter your level of
experience or area of work too
and today I am so excited to be joined
by my co-host for the day matali
krishnaraj Global delivery lead pricing
and analytics platform at AXA Excel
and mentally I would love to have you
just start by me introducing yourself
and telling us a little bit about your
role the company and maybe also
something you like to do in your free
time outside of work
sure sure thank you Rachel that's quite
a warm welcome uh and it's nice to be
here because being
um you know a customer on the other side
of our studio and uh I keep telling this
to everyone uh that it's become a
product which I Started Loving so much
uh so I'm glad to be in the data science
hangout today and I'm maithili Krishna
Raj I'm part of global delivery lead for
AXA Excel for pricing and analytics
platform I've been in the industry for
more than 20 years in terms of insurance
and Technology
um have played different roles in terms
of data and Technology uh today I'm here
to share some of the experience with the
art studio we had over the two years in
terms of the maturity of the platform
within the organization
um and um free time yes I am a busy mom
with two kids
but my older one is 16 and uh the Inga
one is nine now so I'm getting a lot
more time I can say I started my
Executive MBA in March this year so
pretty busy with all that but I love
reading
um and I love also like some artwork
like glass art or crochet or sewing
um so that's what about me and I'm so so
happy to be here today thank you
thank you so while we wait for questions
to come in from everybody I'm curious
what's something that you're really
excited about thinking about the data
science team in the next year ahead
okay so uh it's a very exciting year for
us huh because um when I was talking
about our studio it's been on on premise
um servers uh for almost from 2018 I
joined uh this team two years back uh
taking the management of completely the
platform uh but it's been on on-prem and
we are in the process of migrating
everything to Cloud uh we started the
work this year and this is going to be
one of our strategic platform uh for the
pricing and analytics world uh so I
wanted to see the product getting
evolved and again that's going to be a
completely different experience in terms
of again bringing the maturity and also
you know always the operational cost
comes for discussion whenever we do such
migrations and getting the platform
there so I'm really looking forward for
that
that's great so to be able to put us all
in kind of your team's mindset would you
be able to give us an example of some of
the work that your team's doing
sure so um when I said I mean delivery
or Global delivery lead pricing
analytics means uh like platform means a
lot for different organizations let me
put it in you know in an easier box uh
so uh the platform lead comes with
responsibilities in terms of security uh
because AXA Excel being you know one of
the global players and also insurance
and commercial space
um it's very much data privacy gdpr and
all the other security regulatory is
quite hard for us we have to be very
very careful with the data we handle and
also with all the Integrations of
different systems so my role is to
ensure that I'm aligning to all the
security policies that is put forward by
information security as well as it also
comes with operational work like all the
data analytics work and all the data
science work pricing work because we use
our studio also for pricing
um because in insurance if you see we
have pricing as one of the important
functionality of underwriting so we use
it for that as well so we have to ensure
that the platform is stable and there is
one property model we have for pricing
which I can say that 24x7 it should be
up running
um so that is again it comes under my
responsibility and apart from that you
know definitely the budgets right so
anything you run in terms of platform
it's not that you have huge investment
to do so with the budgets like given
budgets and also considering what is
coming in terms of expansion from
different users I have to ensure that
everything goes by line so that's quite
you know in a summary and along with
that it comes all the other
responsibilities that's tied to it
thank you that's really helpful
I see Alice just started us off with
some questions in the chat and um Alice
mentioned she can't unmute right now so
I'm going to read the question for her
but it's hi I'm curious what were the
key factors that led you to want to
migrate to the cloud and how many data
folks do you have in the organization
okay so um the main reason why we are
moving to cloud is not only for this
particular platform
um it's it's the whole decision of the
corporate or taken by AXA and then AXA
Excel by 2023 we wanted all the data
centers to be gone
um and we went with private cloud and
now it's more of hybrid choosing private
and public
um it's it's the decision of moving to
cloud is again you know different
reasons one is the operational cost
definitely because if you see we had uh
so when I say AXA Excel we are part of
excel group and Excel group acquired
Catelyn
um then we were again you know acquired
by AXA so we have like say three
Integrations gone into this whole of
this acquisition and because of that the
Technologies Jack is huge and we are
trying to streamline everything and in
terms of the cost also we wanted to say
that okay move it to cloud and cloud is
also you know way of looking into saying
by demand you put on the infrastructure
rather than just giving the maximum so
that is the thought process behind but I
will also yes agree to a point that
cloud could be pricey uh it could come
up with its own you know a different way
of configuring it and uh but since we
know how much we have spent all these
years in terms of on-prem we have some
something like on comparative basis and
we'll try to be within that
um but I can't promise saying that
definitely it's going to be cheaper than
the on-prem
thank you
I had a question
um as well I know we we get to talk
about this a little bit um and you talk
to a few weeks weeks ago about it but I
know you do you did a lot around the
governance and security of the platform
and I would love to just hear what your
experience has been like going through
that process because I know there's a
lot of people who might be listening in
who are just starting off with that in
their own organizations
sure so um you know it's a quite uh you
know I'm going to be talking about this
I think throughout my career because
this is something which I have really
enjoyed doing it so uh the platform when
I man started managing it two years back
um it it was uh you know
um all managed by the business users uh
so there was a bit of uh you know uh
hidden detail I can say like a black box
uh we don't know what was the models
that were sitting there uh also we don't
know who were the users because it was
being expanded to different departments
within the organization it started like
a POC and I think it started expanding
to different uh business units because
they saw the benefits that was coming
out of it and then it was also picked up
by one of the biggest property model
pricing uh so it had its own you know
visibility in terms of or we can do some
in this platform all these things and
from always from the for the users who
have been on Excel sheet for some time
uh you are giving a platform which comes
with its own benefits uh they will love
to use it so that's how it started
onboarding there was very very thin line
of support already there when I say
support that was in terms of making sure
the servers doesn't go down and also
onboarding the new users so that was the
minimal thing I saw when I entered this
um unit and then I have to take
um the maturity as my priority because
as I said earlier
um the operational cost is something you
know has a delivery leader I have to
make sure that we are within that and
also security uh because uh Tech debt
and security became priority after
acquisition for us so with all this as
my main objectives I said without even
knowing what is there inside that black
box it'll be very difficult so we
started with the Journey of the maturity
or what I was talking about uh it was
due diligence that first I wanted to do
in terms of understanding what has gone
in the system and also how to bring the
stabilization of the platform because we
also had complaints that it was mainly
for the property pricing
um the platform was coming down
um and they were not knowing the reason
what was happening uh is it with the
servers is it with the network is it
with the application uh so that's where
I think our studio team also really
helped us and Kevin Hayden is here so he
was so helpful
um he got the engineers and we did a
complete architecture review so due
diligence was going on one side the
inventory uh I will also tell how I did
the inventory because that might be
useful for many many of them here so
it's a huge organization different
departments I don't know anyone in
person as well so what we did was and
they're all spread across the global
region so what we said was okay let's
start doing a questionnaire so it was a
simple question or prepared with you
know lot more questions for us to First
understand who are you what are you
doing here and what is your pipeline and
how many you know models you have what
is your data sources and that that was
the type of the questions and we sent it
out we collected all the information
which was very very helpful for us to
say that okay this is what the platform
is getting used for and then one by one
we need to come out with the plan of uh
we call that as application currency
because you know we we
um also quantify that whatever changes
you bring into the platform so we
started with those projects to get to
the maturity level and there were quite
a lot that has been done over the two
years and still I'm saying that we are
in still in progress
um I won't say it's closed because you
know for a platform like this where we
have
um in number of users we can talk about
IDE users we have around 200 to 250
users and in terms of connect viewers we
have around thousand two hundred and
fifty uh so for such a platform you know
it never goes there is still work we are
it's going
did you learn a lot more about the team
through that survey I think that's a
great idea of surveying the users see
how they're actually using it yes uh
definitely because I want to hear both
the you know the positive and the
negative side like what were they
getting from technology because I belong
to technology so I want to understand
one thing I am very much you know
um I can say that that's something I
keep it as you know one of my main
objectives also business uh users are
doing something in a platform means that
they are already you know creating some
business value it's all coming back so I
I'm Keen to help the business Community
but at the same time being a from
technology I need to ensure you know the
technology guidelines are also followed
so I think that particular survey helped
us to think what are the challenges they
are seeing from technology and also to
understand you know what they want us to
do going forward in terms of their
pipeline
um and also certain things like how are
they connecting to data sources and you
know so it was both it's a very very
insightful I think answers which we got
I'm so excited to have you here today to
be able to provide that like I.T and
Technology background and your
perspective because I know a lot of
times there's questions on here about
working with it for the first time and
as a data scientist how do you like
build relationships with I.T and I see
somebody asked synonymously what's the
relationship between data scientists and
I.T or platform team like at your
company
um I will say very very collaborative ah
the see uh one thing I believe in is uh
technology cannot achieve what they want
to achieve without the business and it's
the same for business users also the
data scientists they can't do what they
want without the technology because some
of these requests which is coming from
them simple example I'll give you in
terms of the packages they need for
example right sometimes when it comes to
us we need to understand the importance
of it and quickly turn it around and at
the same time they are deployments so
now recently we implemented proper
deployment release management for all
our models so nothing goes to production
without going through the deployment uh
which we call it as release management
and there you know I can understand B in
20 years in technology for other
applications it's okay we get that
particular build after say three days or
four days or even a month planning can
be done but for analytics they want
something to the market very quickly
they wanted to give the scoring models
to Underwriters they wanted to give the
pricing models very quickly in terms of
you know change in inflation and things
like that
um so what we did was I have to come up
with a different plan of release
management
um saying that okay let's put you know
let's customize it we won't read every
model as an application and go through
the entire change management uh we will
go through a very very thin line uh only
the minimal right the basics what we
need to do in terms of the guidelines so
we have to customize everything for our
data scientists and I think they saw
that when first when I talked about
bringing in God rails and you know uh
all that they were thinking oh this is
going to be complicating what we do now
we are not going to have the flexibility
and we are not going to have that
efficiency which we had earlier but now
they are seeing why did I do it and how
come it has streamlined their process
and now it's you know it's become like
more easy for me to go and tell them
this is what I'm planning to do for the
next phase so I took time but I think
now it's been two years and without
their help I will not be able to do
anything
it's really really helpful perspective
to hear do you have any any tips for uh
for everybody listening in if they're
just getting started working with the IT
team yes so you know the major the tips
is really for the IT team to understand
the value of what you're doing uh
because everything you do like data
scientists there is something going to
be an output it could take one week it
could take a month or even it could take
six months which you are doing an r d uh
but for them to understand the value
we're going to bring in is going to be
very very important and also explaining
to them the flexibility you need because
analytics and you know the data science
is all about the speed that comes with
any platform it could be any platform
right so that is something which you
need to explain to them I'm fine I'm
here to support in terms of the
governance or security or stability what
you want to bring in even the
operational cost but at the same time
can I get this so it's always you know
two ways so if you say I'm going to be
really supportive of your guard rails
but at the same time I'm expecting this
from your team I think it's going to be
more good and definitely I feel that
that collaboration is required
um like I said otherwise it's very very
difficult to make this platform mature
and one thing what I'm seeing now is
after this journey uh two years Journey
the platform has matured and now we both
know how we work I mean each team knows
how we work and there are sometimes
trade-offs both sides but we are able to
take up that the reason being finally we
wanted to give the best to the output
for our business and for the business to
earn the profits what they want uh so
finally for the objective is same both
for technology and the data scientist
world but I think where that sort of
conflict comes in is um you know when
objectives there is no shared Vision so
to get that shared Vision I think both
teams need to talk
um that's very important
absolutely I see there's an anonymous
question that came in and I think it'd
be helpful to clarify
um for people here they said how did the
decision of using our studio as the
cloud service provider come to fruition
how did you ever overcome the question
of why not AWS or Azure or Google kind
of question so could you clarify a
little bit about the class
definitely so I think it's it's I mean I
won't take the entire credit like I said
it's the users it's the business users
um I think I mentioned this to Kevin
some time back they saw the flexibility
that comes with our studio uh when I say
flexibility it's not like just you know
without any God rails going and using it
they know that the entire governance is
there but what they saw it is like the
IDE now after the workbench we have the
launcher so which they felt that it's
one of the good functionality that came
out because you know you have python
Jupiter notebook anything they can
launch and also package Age Management
and the other thing is the you know the
ease easy of like day going and
developing something and then publishing
it to shiny uh so the property model
which I'm talking about is entirely
built on shiny
um and like past two years
um you know we have not had any major uh
failures in terms of the platform even
though the users are expanding and you
know we have it on on-prem with servers
still the business is able to do what
they wanted to do
um the data scientists so that's one of
the reason you know their inputs
convinced even our architecture to think
that we cannot lose our studio and
another
um advantages uh the r studio uh
completely you know the way it can be
installed like how we are doing now an
IDE now if we want to copy the image and
set it up uh we also have very good
scenarios we have got a complete IDE set
up with 2-3 days
so that is something which is going to
be helpful even when we go in Cloud it's
going to be more placed on containers
but if we wanted to do something very
quickly it can be launched so that is
something you know it was useful for us
to convince
um yes there was a debate about um you
know even using other competitive
platform and also we had Usher and all
that but finally our studio won the case
and I know this is an anonymous question
so I'm just guessing as the follow-up
but just to
um
to clarify so you took the our studio
team environment and installed it in the
cloud provider of your choice though
yes that's right it's going to be on
containers and we have still not decided
the entire infrastructure architecture
it's ongoing now
um but we have decided that our studio
is going to be one of our strategic
Solutions
awesome I I see Robert just asked a
question he said he's eating lunch so I
will ask what is the structure of your
it team if you could share who
specifically are you collaborating with
on projects
so
um uh technology team is quite um it
team is quite huge now I am part of uh
Dia with data and analytics department
but I used to work for Global Technology
till March this year since we are almost
you know all all the time we are
involved with pricing and analytics team
I am a part of data science our
department has been moved uh but it I
was working in global technology and
even now which we are integrating you
know all our applications and also like
security governance everything still I
have to be you know liaising with the
technology team so in technology team
since I said it's a huge organization we
have infrastructure support separately
under infrastructure we have uh Unix
ventil team separate and we have Network
team separate storage team separate and
then we have DBA team separate so these
are all the technology teams who I have
to deal bit and then my team comes with
tech lead application manager and the
support team so that's how the it is
structured so when I say technology it
is starting from procurement uh where we
deal with you know getting the licenses
um it's the entire team that I'm talking
about when I say technology
okay thank you
and and then just a reminder to everyone
if you joined a little bit later you can
also ask questions anonymously through
slido and Hannah will share that again
in the chat right now too I realized for
Zoom the chat doesn't show up that
happened previously when you jump on
um but another question was it sounds
like you have a lot of users and with
200 users I think that's what that's
what you said how did you manage the
governance of that okay so um uh when we
did the due diligence also you know
there were already some good things
happening like their onboarding of users
was not just the license was given they
were put in different ad groups so that
helped us so the per there will be some
users who just wanted to use only IDE
and not publish any content to the
connect
um like say they don't build anything in
Chinese so they were like put into
different area groups so that was there
but one thing what it was lacking is we
didn't know who were the users on
boarding and even if there is a lever we
didn't know that person has left and we
need to revoke their access completely
so that we could take the license back
uh so the governance was thought about
okay what can we do in terms of each
step so first is the license how do you
get them like on board and then how do
you keep an audit rail off when are they
leaving what are they doing and say
there will be some users they get the
license but unfortunately they are not
able to use the application for say five
months six months so we started putting
a timeline around it if they don't use
the platform for six months we wanted to
get in touch with them and find out
whether they need the license otherwise
we take the license out of them so
everything has been put in terms of
onboarding and in terms of governance
like I said we have segregated the
environments now so we have the
development and the production separate
um so in development also we have
staging and non-prod so when they are
developing the models when they are
going to publish it they need to come
through the again a ticket which comes
to us to my team and then we go through
it what are they deploying and what is
the model and where which is the data
sources and have they used any sort of
hard code passwords because those are
all the things we have filtered now
um and there is also a validation
framework which we we are using in terms
of validating okay what's happening are
they using licensed libraries are they
using the proper packages packages is
one good thing because we have again it
only can go through my team so any
packages that is requested my team will
be installing them and now uh if we need
to uh say download it from some website
we need to whitelist it that is a
separate team we need to send the
request for white listing and I need to
approve it uh otherwise all our packages
come from Imran the Microsoft ran and
that's how we are managing the
governance for new users
that's really interesting that you can
love to see oh you haven't used this in
in six months what is the problem here
or how can we help also so
I'm curious is there is there like a
program in place for people that in that
place in that position like to then help
them learn or understand why they're not
getting value
yes so there is uh even the business
departments have started doing it mainly
the data scientist and the pricing model
uh actuaries we call actuaries are the
ones who are really using this platform
apart from the data scientists the
machine learning Engineers so what they
have is they have started their own are
training uh because they when they get
in they are doing it and we have helped
them with some sort of Wiki uh like
putting all our our resources together
um like even because they need to know
when I on board whom should I go for
request and what happens after that and
if I want to connect to a data source
how how will I do it because that also
my team has to help them so we have put
everything together and we have given it
for the business users as well and also
we have kept it in our platform so that
they can see that uh so that sort of
knowledge uh um you know sharing was
required uh so there is quite enough
support and I think there is a lot of
investment that is being done for
actuaries because that's why you see 250
users now they all are I mean they know
are they are experts now so we are
helping wherever we have to
I see Frank you had a follow-up question
do you want to jump in
I would love to
um I mentioned that uh you are you
approved the packages right the packages
that get used yeah yeah
um the thought that popped into my mind
and perhaps I'm the only one that does
this but if I'm trying to solve a
problem I will Google I will find a
potential solution install the package
try it ah it didn't work
um so what is that like do you approve
everything in crayon and then stuff
that's like randomly on GitHub that
might not be in cran you have to approve
um see uh there is no hard rule that
they can have to use only the packages
from Imran they if they choose from some
other website like say when you Google
and you find it uh v y v it comes for
white listing and this was implemented
recently so it will we need to send out
the request to make it white listing so
that we can use that link to download
the package but one one step what is in
terms of governance is it goes through
my approval so I need to ask several
questions one thing I have to make sure
is there is no vulnerabilities
um that we are exposing right so if that
is the case and mostly I will say that
um we have not come across any time that
uh the users have requested something
and we are not able to get that for them
any any website it could be we see there
is you know it is a proper website and
it has its you know we are we know that
it's not going to to causes any problems
then we are happy to go ahead with that
do you have an SLA for how fast
no I mean to be honest it's a very small
team because like I said always
operational cost is also something we
wanted to keep it within so it's a very
small team I hold uh but we we go by you
know the business priority
um if they say something no it's very
very critical because the next week I
need to release this for you know for
the scoring or you know for Underwriters
uh then we try to give that as a
priority uh so that's how we keep and
now I mean for past year we are using
kanban board uh where we keep all our
tasks everything including installation
of packages and it could be anything
related to governance and security We
are following a gel model there and we
pull out the tasks based on the
priorities and we know who's working on
that if doesn't come back why it's not
coming back so I think in terms of
project management also we have picked
up this agile way of doing it so it's
very quick
very sensible thank you no problems
thanks
it seems like a lot of people really
like that question Frank so it might be
helpful to dive a little bit deeper into
that one too
um was there a time where the data
scientists had to explain like the
importance of these packages and what
these packages really mean to
the IT team who maybe didn't yet know
what what they were or the value
um yes sometimes they need to because
you know they could be asking it from
some other websites outside so sometimes
yes they need to explain why it could be
very very useful for them in terms of
some functions and like I said this is
one of the main platforms for our
actuaries as well as the data scientists
so we can't say you know just bluntly no
to it so we also put in time to see is
there anything that we could do about it
is there an alternative if it is not
there then I'm happy to you know approve
the white listing and also there is
something else we have discussed also in
case we wanted that website to be used
to install a package but we are thinking
that we are not very sure whether that
has any sort of risks that is it is
supposing then what we do is we do the
installation of the package then again
we remove it from whitelisting so that
no one is using it further so that's we
are trying to do
um but like I said many times I think I
can say 99 percent it has gone through
without any issues
thank you I see Melissa you had a
question in the zoom chat do you want to
jump in
yeah sure I'm wondering how you've
handled the conversation with it if you
have about
um open source technology and the risk
that that might pose to companies
security have you ever run into that and
um really any you or anyone on the call
how did you approach that
actually uh for um I mean uh definitely
if anyone wants to jump in I will also
love to hear for AXA Excel open source
was allowed earlier but then it started
becoming very strict that we are not
supposed to be downloading anything
that's why about all this white listing
we can't use it without making it
approved by all the info Security Group
as well so after my approval it goes
through info security they have to
upload then only it goes through so that
was put in uh but earlier they had to go
to open source and they can download it
but now it's very very strict uh but one
thing I wanted to tell us I'm not very
familiar with all the packages but I can
tell you that there is around thousand
packages that is getting used currently
now uh so I am thinking that most of
those packages are available in in Rand
Microsoft run so I think most of the
functionality which our users are using
I think it's coming from validated
package list so that way we didn't end
up you know going through it and there
has been times all also R was downloaded
from open source so that was also
happening python also was similar but
now for past year and a half there is no
way they can do that uh it has to be
going through a proper governance and
then only they can download it it's not
only my team restricting it it's also
the infrastructure team restricting it
thank you I I see a few others can I
jump in Rachel yeah sure thanks so it's
I'm really surprised that scientists get
guard railed in that sense like because
you you do need like a free mind to be
able to bring about Solutions and other
the interesting thing is basically open
source is being used in other places
where uh like with the JavaScript and
like the front end where there's a lot
of vulnerability and that is the actual
space where which needs to be guardrail
um and uh yeah and basically I think
that that's been like the roadblock for
me as a data scientist in every
corporation uh you know trying to put in
solutions to the Forefront yet I feel
inhibited and I feel I am there's
roadblocks there
yeah
um so banjo the whole thing right see
it's again like I said in the start it's
looking at both ways right so I agree to
you definitely because you don't you
lose that sort of you know the
flexibility to get what you want to do
as a data scientist uh but um the the
whole thing is it's not like I said a
very hard rule that nothing should be
got from open source or nothing can be
installed uh we also have a process of
you know uh finding Alternatives other
ways there is also a process called uh
going through you know complete Security
process that all gate and then you know
explaining why do we need this and then
you know we have something called as a
RAM process and if that is being set a
year is set on it like say expiry date
is set on it every year it'll be
reviewed and if we have already got an
alternative they'll close that otherwise
they will continue using it uh so
because not only our platform I I I
manage another application which is for
risk maps and that there we had python
which we have to go into the next
version but their utilities are still
having in the old version of python so
we have got some you know uh buy-in
there
um from security so it's always you know
the business explaining to us why what
is the need for it and then we becoming
you know like almost intermediate in
this process and we going and putting
that forward for security and getting
the approval uh so there are you know we
have like channels which we can use in
terms of when such situation happens
um and the other thing what I wanted to
say is see the risks organizations are
having this huge uh coming from
insurance organization if something goes
wrong even one data gets leaked the
amount of penalty that the organization
has to pay is very huge uh which you
know we can't even quantify how much is
that so that's the risk we hold and the
data privacy is like like really the
topmost priority for us and we have to
ensure that for different applications
so this is one of the applications but
there is quite a lot and the governance
is required otherwise it will be too
hard after a few years because we won't
even know from where the packages have
been downloaded and what each packages
is bringing the vulnerability and it
becomes very very difficult to manage
it's not so much about the packages I
mean I
um
I it's open source is a mindset it's
it's a mindset more so than like a
process right and when we are trying to
do the best for the organization
um it had that that flexibility and that
alignment needs to happen so that we can
bring about the perfect solutions for
the organization and it's the trust in
people that ultimately matters and uh I
have seen a lot of data has got breached
because of like whatever reasons
Outsourcing or whatever and yeah so uh
but the the reality is it's an oh it's a
mindset that needs to be nurtured within
corporations
no definitely I mean I I understand
where you come from Yes it it has to be
nurtured uh but I think it's a balance
um and if we can achieve that balance
it's good for both sides right see
something uh like you said if everyone
is being bit conscious what they are
exactly doing am I every step I do if
I'm being conscious that no I'm not
going to pose a risk then it's fine it's
absolutely fine uh but when it comes to
the reality and everyone doing their
jobs sometimes it's because of the time
pressure or the timelines pressure also
there are chances that they might forget
to check something and you know even
though I'm working in technology all
these years I am still not an expert of
security so that's why we sometimes go
to our security advices to find out
whether is this open source okay and
whether can we allow it and that's why
they keep one more approval after me
that the info security has to approve it
so I think it's again you know like I
said it's a balance there should be if
you really need something there should
not be a complete blunt no
um there should be channels to help you
uh so if organizations could do that I
think it's really nurturing both
mindsets right one side we making sure
you know we are aligning to all our
security at the same time we are also
giving the flexibility for the data
scientists
absolutely I I love that
so what is the like what's the channels
that you recommend for teams to
like yes support or what companies need
to create for your teams to get support
when they're kind of in this this
roadblock space definitely the way we're
right so where they say something is
very very important for data scientists
and they can't they don't get it safe
from the reputed or known uh sites they
wanted to get something uh I will say
please listen to the data scientist uh
and there should be a group who's
sitting and reviewing that right so they
can put a waiver there it can be
approved by their own management say
from who's requesting it the data
scientist managers or their leadership
can look into it and say yes it is
needed because this person is going to
create this business value and we can't
just say no to it so let's put this form
and fill out the form submit it let the
security review it or technology review
it and they can give you a waiver and
you can put a time limit on that if you
don't want to give it say for five years
that's fine every year you can review it
and you can see if there is no
vulnerabilities post then leave it to go
so I think we always I think about this
right when a person is requesting for
something finally it is a business value
he he or she is bringing to the company
so they need to listen and they have to
give them what is the other alternative
right okay if we can't download from
this or we can download but can you
please fill out this form and can you
please get the approval from your own
management so something like that that
is there for every organization I think
it it definitely will achieve a balance
um Italy I have a statement
um yeah it was my observation so it is
not so much about the packages uh yeah
it could be anything yeah no uh within
corporations it is not so much about the
packages it is more so about getting
access to the sources and it is more so
about the quality and that's where
um that's where the roadblocks are
currently uh rather than um rather than
the packages themselves you see that
yeah you can wear the problems lie
within organizations So when you say
access Manju are you talking about data
sources yes the data okay so like how
they are being aligned and where they
are within like which yeah and things
like that that's the actual those those
are the actual issues which need to be
addressed
again I think it's the maturity of the
technology right uh because
um say okay I can give you an example
right say a data source uh is being
accessed all the years using say a SQL
server ID which you got it created okay
you're accessing a SQL server and they
have given you an ID for your name okay
you have been using all that for many
years and you have been sharing your ID
and password even with other of your
peers uh that that is it posed a risk
because the reason is the data that
might be sitting in that data source
could be confidential or it could be
even you know very much it shouldn't be
shared it should be secured right but if
it is given to you and your name is
registered it's fine only Manju is uh
accessing it but say you are sharing
that ID and password with someone else
right it it is a risk so what happens in
those scenarios is the organization
comes out with their policy okay so you
wanted to access the data that's fine
but we'll create a service account and
that password will not be given to you
it will be in cyber Arc or something
where the rotation of passwords happen
and every 60 days it gets renewed so
that's what I'm saying for every instead
of just telling to you no you can't
access that they have to come out with
an idea of how can it be accessed with
governance uh so that's where you know
the governance plays a bigger role in
entire you know technology world
I love I love this discussion I want to
make sure we get to a lot of the other
questions that are here too
um no but one one quick follow-up
question from that was do you have
separate
um Dev and prod environments
yes we do uh so we have uh Dev prod and
also we have staging environments uh
because some of the things that our team
like wanted to test say for example we
were like moving to work bench last year
so we wanted to install everything we
wanted to try out we use one environment
where we don't have data scientists at
all so we have such an environment and
also we have like for the users to try
out anything in terms of their trial
like the lower environment once
everything is ready that's where they
submit the ticket okay everything is
done and I have my data sources and I
have my algorithms ready and now I need
to deploy this or publish this content
then it goes through the quickest way
right that's what I explained we have
customized it because say there is a
dashboard which someone has built it for
uh within a two days and it has to be
immediately going to production and we
see it's a very simple dashboard not
many external data sources are there and
there is no sort of any security that we
need to validate then what we do is we
give an SLA of even one two three hours
it will be published in the production
but say if it is a model which they also
have built it for say six months three
months or nine months and it has got
quite a lot of data sources and also
there is some hard coded password
sitting in the code uh then that goes
through its you know little bit of
validation again it's I'm not talking
about it will take a week again there
the SLA is two to three days
thank you it's very helpful an anonymous
question from earlier was how far out
into the future do technology teams at
your org have to think about uh when it
comes to adopting new technology
uh we have to think about little bit I
mean I can say yes we all have to think
about it's not only my organization uh
but at the same time uh we also have
Legacy
um quite a lot uh the reason being even
new technologies come in it's not easy
for us to shift uh because of the
expansion that happened over the days uh
so it's it's been you know not that easy
for us to think about a new technology
and immediately adopt that
um and again now the procurement process
again we need to go through we can
conduct pocs we can conduct MVP and if
it is all fine then we can submit the
proposal but again there we are talking
about budget so we need a business
sponsor who's supporting it and what is
the reason that we are shifting to a new
technology uh there should be a proper
business case with both tangible and
intangible benefits then only we can
move
thank you I just realized on that Dev
test prod environment question I see
Javier you had a related question do you
want to jump in
hey I can yeah
um I've Loved this conversation it's
been awesome so thank you and and some
of some of my like some of the question
that I asked I think was already
discussed and answered but
let's say I'm a data scientist at your
company and I have pretty much built an
entire you know ETL pipeline
um and like a shiny app like I've built
everything but your team owns the
deployment of this tool to production
yes that's right
let's say I have to make an update which
could take me 30 seconds to do so I I
you know submit the commit uh you know I
it's on GitHub or gitlab and I reach out
to you
um do the data scientists at your
company have the ability to push that
change to prod themselves or do they
still need to file
a zero ticket and you know wait up to
two weeks for this okay so they have the
ability to yeah so no definitely no
waiting time of two weeks and there is
also you know we wanted to give them
access from like automated checkout from
GitHub and going into production that is
also possible and since we are moving
into Cloud the devops is going to get
involved and it's going to be all
automated the cicd pipeline so then it
becomes very quick but now now on-prem
also that's what I said the maximum we
are taking is only two to three days
um otherwise it's like say to us or
three years even one hour say there is a
change like you explained to us that it
has to be done maybe instead of 30
seconds it's going to take an hour
that's all so it's not a major
difference but we also have a checkout
process from GitHub which is going to be
very automated
do you has this been defined in your
internal like sock 2 controls or socks
controls do you have you know this
mechanism defined in your
um you know Internal Documentation so
for us uh because like I said since I am
owning pricing an analytics platform I
have customized this release process
little bit different what our
information security calls out is you
definitely need to have non-production
and production you can't do your
development in production please do it
and then go through release management
we have a change request that we need to
submit but what I have done is since it
is data scientist and pricing actuaries
they can't wait for every change the
change request to be raised and going
through the entire process if I have an
auditing mechanism that I can document
it then I have you know the flexibility
to customize it that's why I have done
it that way so if it is a small change
change no implications and it can go
within one hour we send it within one
hour they need not go through the entire
change request process that we do for
all the other applications
okay I may reach out to you on LinkedIn
definitely completely this conversation
there if you don't mind no definitely
I'm happy to help I told this to Rachel
I mean anything that could be a takeaway
from this meeting please feel free to
reach out to me whatever information I
can share with you guys definitely I
will love to do it thank you so much no
problem and I just put
um my Tilly's um
LinkedIn in there because it looks like
the wrong LinkedIn got linked on the uh
data science hangout page that that push
should be going up in a few minutes but
just in case there's a delay there we
put it in yeah sure
um Trevor I see you had a question you
just put into the chat I think was a
follow-up on the open source evaluation
process do you want to jump in
yeah hi everyone hi
this is really interesting very very
nice conversation we're having I'm just
I'm I don't know if I could work in your
environment
yeah you are welcome Trevor ah because
um data science is is a creative process
sometimes and you know you're trying to
find a package that meets your needs at
the moment and if I if each time I want
to try a new package it may take me two
to three days
um that's creating a bottleneck that is
really preventing us from being
efficient so it's more a comment than
than a question but the real question is
around
um so given that open source packages
are can be unique and you know many
variations
the how do you go about guarantee in two
to three days because a package may be
simple with one function or you could
have a package with several functions um
what are you looking for when you're
looking at the packages and and how do
you guarantee given your
you're a small team as you describe
um the ability to meet your SLA of
really two to three days
let's see um it's a very good question
it it was not easy like I said it's a
small team uh but you know one thing
what we have done is there is a
validation framework we have done uh
like scripting on the server side which
will go through very quickly in terms of
your validation of your libraries and
packages and then we have like also
there is a scanning team which does the
scanning for hard-coded passwords or
anything so it is a um I will say
everything is not manual there is like
we have to come up see that is the
maturity I'm talking about when I
started the discussions everything like
governance security everything has to be
done manually it's going to take its own
time it's like the testing work times
right when you automate your testing
it's very quick so similar things for
governance also if you can make anything
automated in terms of validating them
then any team can turn around say
deployment to production within few days
but you have to come out with those
ideas so that's why I keep saying this
is a like a journey we have taken up the
journey like last year but still we are
working on it and you know the the next
big thing for coming for us is the NFS
storage cleanup there is also cleanup
going on parallely as we do all these
things but I always motivate the team to
come up with some sort of Automation in
terms of the scripting so that we can
make this validation very quickly
yeah so so so so follow-up question so
your data science teams our team our
teams that you work with what is your
job job satisfaction like I mean
actually that's a good question you know
I can't just uh claim here that oh they
are all very happy that uh I'm doing
this sort of you know work
um but you know one thing like I said
right they are collaborating a lot
compared to you know when I started when
I approached them and I talked about
governance so I feel that now they are
able to understand it's both ways
because tomorrow when we are moving into
Cloud all the work that I have been
doing for this past two years is going
to be very helpful because we did an
inventory of completely all the
applications and also the data sources
what they are connected to
um and if tomorrow if we go to them and
we could have asked all this detail
maybe there is you know a chance that
they won't even know and they will be
saying they are going to take few weeks
to find it out so they there is both
ways right I have made their life bit
easier with all this inventory and the
governance which I have put forward and
now since the deployment is done through
release management we also having a
tracker for that so we know the models
when it is developed when it is changed
which dates it's been changed and it's
going through the ticket to get it to
production so all this data that is
getting gathered with the governance and
security is going to help them so I
think they they should be happy uh that
is my assumption but uh yeah maybe I
have to take a 360 feedback and find out
I think
it's also really helpful for everyone to
understand that this came as a request
from the business to be able to use our
studio and buy you going through that
process and putting the governance
around it it allowed them to be able to
use the tool that they wanted to instead
of just being forced into something else
too yes that's right but I think that
they have been very
I could have not done this nothing I
could have done because when we sent out
the inventory the first time they came
up with their responses very quickly
what what exactly they are looking
forward for the technology to do for
them and also giving the information
what they had so I think it has been
quite helpful from their side
absolutely I see there was a slider
question I missed a little bit earlier
that was is digital transformation still
a word that's used as an org-wide
initiative if not what are the new
orguide initiatives to Future proof your
business
I mean digital transformation is quite
it's becoming a buzzword across the
industry so uh not everything we do is
called the digital transformation
sometimes you know it is done but
without even naming it as digital
transformation uh but there are also
teams uh where we have digital
transformation teams on the data site uh
so there are teams by that name uh but I
won't call it as every initiative we
pick up it's called as a digital
transformation uh there is so much that
going on without it getting tacked under
digital
great thank you I did just have a a
question about your environment if I get
to ask one with a few minutes left so I
know you said you have both R and python
users now and so are both sets of users
in the same environment now or do you
also manage different tools for each no
we they are all in the same environment
and even before the workbench there was
some very little usage of python that
time they had a server where they were
using it but now after this we don't
have separate environments we have our
IDE as one of the main thing because
workbench we purchased it last year so
after that I think it's only our
platform that's getting used now uh but
but there are also you know in other
departments
um there are other competitor platforms
uh but we have to see when we move to
Cloud uh what is getting you know
segregated R is going to be there
definitely our studio is going to be
there but along with that what other you
know platforms are going to be or also
given to the community we are not very
sure of
and is there
so I know you did the survey to figure
out what how people are using certain
tools but if there's other future
languages or things that people want to
use how do they start to introduce that
it has to go through the POC process and
earlier on I mean I'm talking about like
because now it's my 13th year in the
organization but before that we used to
have like anything you wanted to try you
can try and then go and you know put
that as a business case and get it but
now we need to go through the
procurement just to make sure even the
POC departments I mean they know that
they have to go through procurement they
have to reach out to the vendor get the
product and try it and if we like it
then go with it so
um there if they wanted new languages or
anything or they want new platform it
has to go through the procurement
process and like I said it also has to
be justified why are we moving into new
technology and uh the benefits of it
awesome I don't see any any other
questions but I just want to say thank
you so much mentally for thank you yes
it was so helpful to to hear your
perspective and experience here no thank
you very much thank you very much for
the art studio team as well because I
think throughout this journey I'm
talking about I don't know how many
times I've asked my team to reach out to
our studio and especially Kevin and say
that oh this is very much urgent for us
can you please help us uh so I I should
really thank uh even heart Studio team
for that and uh yeah I look forward to
be you know working long time in this
let's see how that goes that's awesome
you just reminded me I wanted to say
this as well if anybody is ever curious
if your team is using our Studios
products or if you want to be connected
with your rstudio account manager
I can't believe how many times that
there will be teams who who reach out
who just don't know that their their
colleagues are using our tools yet
um feel free to reach out to me in like
the least salesy way possible like can
just let you know I'll put my my
LinkedIn on here too if you ever just
wanted
to ask and are curious but thank you all
so much for joining today and for all
the great questions too we will see you
back hopefully next week we also have an
awesome meet up next Tuesday
um at 12 eastern time with Julia silvey
and Isabelle Zimmerman on using
um or ml Ops with vetiver in R and
python so I am also just going to put
the short link real quick
to that Meetup if you want to just add
it to your calendar too
awesome well thank you everybody thank
you
bye